This method is also cleaned up a bit got rid
of some of the variable that we don't really need
anymore. So the first thing we do is if the
user is null we throw an unauthorized exception. The next
thing to do is to get the main email as
the user's email and get the user ID. Then we
get the display name sent by the request and the
TeeShirtSize, sent by the request. Then, this is new. We load
the profile. Might not be there, but we go ahead
and load it anyway. Then we need to check, that it
actually existed. So, check if it's now, then if it
is now, that means it didn't already exist. We need to
set the display name, either to the value passed in
the profile form or otherwise if the display name wasn't parsed,
get the default name. And again, similarly with the tee shirt,
get the value passed by the form. And it fits null,
set it to default which is not specified.
In this case, not specified. And then we
need to create, actually create the profile. So
this was our call, it's our call to
create the new profile. However, the profile already exists. Just call,
update method, parsing the displayName, and the teeShirtSize.
Which remember, one or either of these could in fact be null. And then
we save it in the data store as we did before. Here the code has been made more
concise, and we return the profile. Now let's take
a look at profile.java to look at the update
method, which is pretty simple. Takes a displayName and
the TeeShirtSize, checks each one if they're null. If
they are null, doesn't do anything with that property.
If they're not null, that means the user updated
that value. So, update the appropriate property, that's
all it does. This doesn't do the saving,
because remember, we do the saving back here
in save profile. All right, let's see if
it actually works. So I deployed to local host and came over to the, our old
friend API's explorer. We have some profiles, so
let's see what they are. So get existing
profile, and you see that the name is Apple Turnover, and the tee shirt size is
XS. So remember that, Apple Turnover, XS. Now let's save the profile. And we're
just going to update one of the properties.
Let's change the display name to Icecream Cake.
So we'll save that, and the exist, remember
that the existing tee shirt size is XS,
so let's see what happens. Okay, good. So the display
name was set to Icecream name, but the tee shirt size
was left as XS. So now we know that we
didn't get a new profile, we just updated the existing profile.